too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
think about what the next step from
there is that really threatens the
foundation of our Republic joining me
now is JD Vance Ohio's Republican
candidate for U.S Senate JD thank you
for being with us 74 million Americans
apparently are extremists now how is
that a winning strategy campaign
strategy for Biden and the Democrats
well I don't think it's a winning
strategy at all because it ignores the
fact that Joe Biden has effectively been
in a positional leadership for 30 years
in this country and what has happened uh
in 30 years uh we basically haven't won
a war uh we have had Rising suicide
rates we have Rising mortality rates
such the life expectancy of the country
has come down we've lost a long-term
battle against the Chinese and Joe Biden
is actually taking us in the wrong
direction and fighting us back and and
given all that you would expect him
maybe to take some responsibility for
the fact that the country's not doing
well and instead he's decided that the
enemy is not him not the people who have
made bad decisions but the Patriotic
Americans who are frustrated enough
about their country that they love to
work to change it and I just can't
imagine anything more divisive and more
dangerous coming from a President Who if
he said anything during his campaign it
said he would unite the country this is
not uniting at all he's declaring war
effectively on half of the country not
just Donald Trump I understand he
doesn't like Donald Trump but on Donald
Trump's voters and I can't imagine a
president ever doing that in in American
history JD this reaction to Biden's
speech from CNN well I I was doubled
over when I heard it
he almost seemed to sort of be
reclaiming patriotism often you hear
Republicans argue that they are the
pro-america party right the Democrats
are not patriotic enough but what was
more pro-usa than this speech JD
reclaiming patriotism what happened to
it JD Biden's party were saying waving
American flags were racist not so long
ago
yeah if you just look at the backdrop of
this I mean it looked like it was
designed by a guy who was intentionally
trying to create you know ridiculous
evil propaganda imagery uh it's not
reclaiming patriotism to declare war on
half of your citizens Joe Biden is the
president of a shared American Nation
and he basically looked to the camera
and said half of you are evil people
half of you are bad people that's not
patriotism that's a recipe for division
and for attack and look at the end of
the day the country had serious problems
that serious problems because of the
decisions that Joe Biden has made over
the last couple of years he could accept
some responsibility and promise a new
Direction instead he decided to attack
the people who are rightfully angry
about his failed leadership we've got to
fight back against this and I'd say if
people want to help us fight back
jdvance.com support our candidates
running because that's the only thing
that's going to provide a check to what
we saw tonight JD I want to play with
your Democratic opponent Tim Ryan had to
say about his party today watch
don't advertise that you're a Democrat
is that because there's an implicit
recognition it's a liability here yeah
well I mean the Democratic brand as we
know and you and I've talked about this
for a long time is is not good in a lot
of these places and I tell people look
I'm an American JD I have 20 seconds
left how do you think he feels tonight
about being a Democrat
well I think he probably feels even
worse but maybe he should stop voting
100 with Joe Biden Nancy Pelosi and
actually fight back that's exactly what
we're trying to do which is why we've
got to send these Democrats especially
in the Senate races pack income November
and Jada your neck and neck with Ryan so
we'll keep our eye on that race thank
you for being here hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else